ces pêcheurs français sont en pleine
prise de poissons et de crustacés
cette pêche laurent merlin la réalise
chaque jour dans les eaux territoriales
britanniques mais avec le break site
tout pourrait être remise en cause allez
on a très peur de le bref que le baril
soit très dur mais si on peut plus venir
dans les eaux anglaises on passe la
plupart du temps dans les eaux anglaises
du coup ça serait la fin de notre métier
ce lundi le royaume uni et l'union
européenne ont repris leurs discussions
sur les relations post break site avec
en tête les accords commerciaux pour le
moment le royaume uni s'oppose fermement
à la volonté de l'union européenne
d'avoir un accès durable aux eaux
britanniques la fin de l'accès des
pêcheurs de l'ue aux eaux territoriales
britanniques n'auraient pas d effet que
sur les pêcheurs les marchés aux
poissons comme celui de boulogne sur mer
serait aussi grandement les et ce qui
est certain c'est que l'impact potentiel
pour nos activités de mareyage
sur sur bologne ac est le premier port
de pêche de france on l'estiment aux
alentours de 1/3 de l'activité donc ce
qu'est carré mais quelque chose
extrêmement important d'après sky news
la majorité des poissons pêchées dans
les eaux britanniques sont pris par des
pêcheurs étrangers les britanniques
vente également une partie de leur prise
en dehors de leur territoire un accord
commercial semble donc indispensable
pour garantir la survie de la pêche
we need to find nous avons besoin de
trouver un accord sinon les difficultés
sociales et économiques auxquels nous
serons confrontés se traduiront
évidemment par des tensions et peut-être
aussi par des affrontements en mer
important entre les pêcheurs britannique
et ceux d'autres pays européens
ce serait une catastrophe walfoot be à
kadhafi l'union européenne fait
maintenant aussi face à l'urgence dans
sa volonté de sauver la pêche dans les
eaux britanniques lui et le royaume uni
espère trouver un accord d'ici à la fin
de l'année